c'est la reine des fleurs là plusieurs
dorante laroche de damas
la délicate récolte commence à l'aube
c'est à ce moment que la fleur se fera
l'oeil avisé de virgin d'air kumar ils
sillonnent les champs de rose et de
jasmin depuis 25 ans
il faut choisir celles qui sont matures
et qui s'ouvre complètement
explique-t-il à lui seul vergine des
récoltes chaque jour entre 30 et 40 kg
de fleurs
une porte des gants mais il est habitué
aux blessures il ne sent presque plus
les piqûres d épines
une cinquantaine de cueilleurs viennent
vendre leurs fleurs aux grossesses
mohamed faye qui les revend suite à une
vingtaine de 10 tiers literie les bonnes
rose que celles qui sont abîmés
l'inde a vécu son printemps le plus
chaud en une décennie et la récolte en a
souffert
je dois payer un dollar le kilo droz
explique-t-il alors qu'en temps normal
je peux environ 75 cents
la particularité de la communauté de
canaux se trouvent dans ces salles qui
vous renvoie au moyen âge
la méthode traditionnelle de
distillation est la même depuis 400 ans
on y mélange les fleurs à de l'huile ou
de l'eau pour en faire un parfum sans
alcool c'est ce qu'on appelle la tard
on sait les immenses cuves de terre
cuite pour préserver les arômes ont les
chauffant suite au bois pendant de
longues heures dans une pièce rapidement
en fumée la vapeur odorantes s'échappe
par une longue tige de bambou et elle
est ensuite récupérée dans un autre
contenant le produit extrait un parfum
floral prisée en inde et en asie et
aussi acheté par des géants du domaine
de la parfumerie comme dior
la chaleur et la fumée sont étouffantes
admet ce travailleur impossible de
rester à l'intérieur très longtemps
[Musique]
les arômes peuvent être combinées comme
cet art qui sent la première pluie sur
la terre desséchée d'été et qui contient
jusqu'à 41 ingrédients végétaux les
méthodes de distillation utilisé à
canaules sont parmi les plus anciennes
du monde encore aujourd'hui quatre
personnes sur cinq vivent directement ou
indirectement de l'industrie du parfum
dans cette petite communauté de 85 mille
habitants il sait philippe laigle à
radio-canada canonge en inde